The World Health Organization estimates that over 121 million people worldwide
suffer from some form of depression.
It is one of the world's most common mental
disorders and with 30 percent of sufferers attempting suicide.
I'm not lying when I say the depression kills.
Creative types have been proven to be the group most affected by this disorder
with people such as Ernest Hemingway Virginia Woolf
and Michelangelo all being affected.
Is this due to nothing but their unique thought processes
or could it be something else.
It has been proven that as a species human beings are drawn to those with
whom we share ideas and have similarthoughts with.
Studies have shown this time and time again
such as in Newcomb's 1956 experiment where
he found that men liked their housemates
more if they had similar attitudes about sex, family and politics.
This is because people enjoy feeling validated are impressed when
others have the same taste as them and
find it easier to talk to those with the same interests.
So it is reasonable to assume that if a person is unable to
find someone with a similar thought process to them
they will become lonely
and may end up suffering from depression.
Creative people have the most unique of minds
and therefore we can draw the conclusion that as cliched as
it sounds no one understands them.
However Newcomb study was flawed in many ways
it's gender bias and small sample size of 17
means that it can't be generalized to the entire population
and it fails to explore deeper levels of thought.
This means that whilst people may be more agreeable
when they have the same views
it doesn't mean those with different views are shunned from society.
So what does cause such levels of
depression in the more creative half of the population.
Akinola and Mendes in 2008 conducted a study that looked at
the role of rejection when it comes to creativity.
Participants were given
either positive negative or no feedback on a speaking test
and then asked to produce a collage.
The participants exposed to negative feedback or rejection
produced more creative collages than participants in
the control group and the positive feedback group.
This suggests that societal rejection a particular symptom
of depression may be responsible for increased creativity.
In other words depression causes creativity
instead of creativity causing depression.
It is crucial to think critically when it comes to the art
in order to reach your optimum capability,
but the problem with overthinking is that self-doubt often follows
and with that lower confidence making it easier to slip into depression.
Perhaps the cause of such mental issues with creative people is that
they get too used to judging their own work and
slowly begin judging themselves.
I know that I am guilty of doing this
as it becomes hard to distinguish between the two
especially when you put so much heart into what you're working on,
it almost becomes a part of you.
The role of an artist is to always dance on the dangerous line
and for many the dance is too hard to keep up.
Do you suffer from the same struggles which theory do you support
depression causing creativity or
creativity causing depression.